i was 20 years old
when i was invited to join the cleveland
summit
one of the first political events to
feature mostly black athletes
the photos of me sitting with jim brown
bill russell
and the others chose me with a very
serious game phase
oh i was serious all right but inside i
was nervous
and a little scared we were there to
decide whether or not to support the
greatest heavyweight fighter in history
muhammad ali and his refusal to be
drafted based on his moral beliefs
as the youngest and least experienced
member of the summit
who was i to have an opinion on such
life-changing matters
ali himself was only 25 and his decision
to fight the draft would cost him his
career
his reputation millions of dollars
and earned him a prison sentence we
vigorously debated ali's sincerity and
commitment
a few of our group were ex-military and
not sympathetic to draft evaders
but in the end we agreed to support him
to witness ali's
unwavering integrity even as the
government spent years trying to destroy
him
was a turning point for me even though
he had to be scared
he risked everything to do the right
thing
how could i do any less how can any
american do any less
how can any american athlete do any less
after all athletes are trained to face
fear and force themselves to overcome it
that's what i did at the cleveland
summit i remembered my most
fearful moment when i was 17 and had to
run
for my life
it was july 18 1964
a hot muggy saturday during my next to
last summer in new york city
before heading off to a yet to be
determined college i had a summer job
working for a local journal
so i decided to walk over to observe a
harlem protest rally
to see if there was something i could
write about nearly a thousand people
had gathered at the police station to
protest the killing of a
fifteen-year-old unarmed
african-american boy
james powell by a white off-duty police
officer
i never made it to the rally i was still
a couple of blocks away
when i heard the gunshots crack in the
air and saw people screaming in terror
as they ran past me looking for cover
i ran too trying to stay as low as i
could
afraid i was already a target because i
was black
but a more visible target because i was
so tall
as i crouched in fear behind a lamppost
it seemed like i was
never going to make it to that yet to be
determined college
as the crowd became more outraged a
police officer with a megaphone tried to
calm the situation
by commanding go home go home
someone in the crowd shouted back we are
home baby
we are whole hearing that simple phrase
helped me control my fear
and in the years that followed helped me
focus my social activism
i think that's the message we've been
trying to get across all these years in
all these protests
america is our home and we want to feel
valued and safe in our homes
how can we feel valued when we are not
given the same benefits as others
how can we feel safe when 56 years after
the protest of the killing
of that unarmed 15 year old boy we are
still protesting the murders of our
children
does that sound like home to you
we can't go for a walk in the park a jog
in our neighborhood
a drive to the market without fear for
our lives
not just from armed civilians but from
hostile police
does that sound like home our children
can't get the same education health care
or career opportunities as white
children
does that sound like home and some of
our neighbors and leaders
protect monuments that honor and admire
the men who raped
brutalized and tortured our ancestors as
well as rip children for mothers
to sell them on a purely patriotic level
why are we memorializing the traders who
nearly destroyed our country
why aren't these monument huggers asking
for more statues of benedict arnold
everybody's equal among the most
impassioned voices echoing the
we are home sentiment are athletes like
colin kaepernick
lebron james steph curry john carlos and
tommy smith
eric reed megan rapino brandon marshall
and dozens of others they spoke up when
it wasn't popular
now it's more important than ever that
athletes continue to speak up
for everybody whether we want it or not
along with the fame and money
comes the responsibility of being role
models
one study shows that children admire
famous athletes
second only to their parents we need to
earn their admiration by doing more than
winning games
we need to make those kids lives better
by giving them all
a level playing field athletes can't
just
take the money and run hoping others
will take all the risks
that will benefit all of us
[Music]
protest is in the american dna
the united states was born out of
violent public protest
starting with the boston tea party and
every major
social and political advancement in our
history
has been the result of people taking to
the streets to voice their demands
public protests created this country in
1776
and almost destroyed it in 1861.
cities have burned people have been
killed
yet each time civil unrest has forced
the country to take an
uncompromising look at itself to judge
if it's on the right course the course
set by the us constitution
this is what unity looks like it has
been said that the ark of the moral
universe is long
but it bends toward justice what
protesters have discovered
is that the ark of the moral universe
only bends toward justice
when pressure is applied
so stand up kneel down
and speak out so the message rings out
loud and clear across the country
we are home baby we are home
you